national master james canty iii here
with chess.com and today
we have game of the day with the white
pieces we have dragon by komodo
and with the black pieces we have zypos
let's get right into it here it is
we have e4 and then e5 knight f3 and
knight f6 a petrov defense or the
russian
implemented from fabiano caruana being
one of the greatest ones to play this
this opening here it's quite annoying
but also quite fun for the black player
but if you don't know what you're doing
you can get in a lot of trouble and it
does throw a lot of people off if you
don't know how to face this here
we recommend that you look at the world
championship games in 2018
from magnus carlson and fabiano so
pretty fun stuff here but after knight
f6 there's d4 which is a newer way to
play we would say
usually you would see knight takes e5
now of course d4 has already been played
but nowadays it's played a little bit
more because there's more action for
white
there's different positions that you
usually don't get with the regular
petrov after knight takes c5 and knight
takes c4
and things like that so we have d4 it's
also a favorite of wesley souls as well
wesley so does play the d4 variation
here
with great success actually so uh
something that you guys should implement
let's take a look at the rest of the
game
knight takes e4 and then bishop to d3
attacking the knight so of course we
always want to keep material count even
unless you're gambiting a pawn for rapid
development or something like that
but here in this case we are just uh
temporarily down upon we're going to get
it back
quite easily here like by taking on e5
so bishop to d3 it attacks tonight so we
have two pieces out developed
and we have d5 here from zypos and then
dragon says
knight takes e5 give me my pawn back
thank you so much here
knight to d7 here now the rule a lot of
times guys is when they cross the line
they have to go
and what is the line the line is
anything one to four and for black it
will be anything
five to eight here so after you cross
over the halfway point into your
opponent's territory
it's vital that you get rid of that
piece they have to go so in this case we
do see the bishop can capture on e4
maybe you'll see something like knight
to d2 or knight to c3 to get rid of this
knight
and black in great fashion is doing
actually the same thing trying to
deprive this knight from the e5 square
because it is in black's territory
after knight to d7 we have knight to c3
here which is an interesting move
it's uh actually inviting a double of
the pawns here
but if if the pawns are doubled if we do
have something like knight takes c3 in
this position
well this bishop has a very long range
here on the king side
hitting the h7 pawn especially after
castling is going to be very vulnerable
for black so pretty nice move here and
actually let's see what happens
actually after bishop to b4 which is a
great move here attacking the knight two
times you would see something like
maybe defend this pawn right because
knight takes c3 to fight uh defended by
the pawn
and then after knight takes c3 you have
pawn takes bishop takes c3
and attacking the king and the rook with
a double attack
so you should defend it right or not
just castle get out of the way and have
a nice day
says dragon here castle what a move here
just getting right out of the way and
saying
you can have the pawn i dare you to take
it and let's see what happens after
castles there's knight takes e5 so of
course we did originally want to do this
anyway
and also expose the bishop just get the
bishop out make sure we have good range
eliminating
a great piece that white had a great
move knight takes c5 d takes
and then zypo says you know what if
you're going to give me a pawn
i'm going to take a pawn so he goes for
it now i take c3
b takes c3 bishop takes c3 and of course
two pawns are attacked here or
two pieces and the pawn and the rook are
attacked so double attack
after bishop takes c3 we see rook to b1
just putting the rook on the file
with a smile very nice here of course
it's only like the best move anyway you
do have something like bishop to a3
which is quite strange it will work
as it cuts off the king but it does uh
it does just
sack the exchange with maybe not the
most um
compensation for it so after bishop
takes c3 we have rook to b1
with putting a rook on this on the file
here again and then castles because if
bishop takes e5 well we run straight
into a pin here this is just a nasty pin
why would we do this you got to get your
king castled right we already took one
pawn let's not take another one until
later
so after rook to b1 we have castles and
then here we go guys
now he says you know what dragon says
hey this position
is pretty fun to play maybe it looks a
little boring we haven't developed a lot
of things here you know what we're just
going to do this right here
bam bishop takes h7 is on the board it's
already there
take away that king protection thanks
for the pawn because after king takes
what we're just gonna get that material
right back
just like that queen d3 with a check and
we're hitting c3 as well
and then king to g8 and we take now in
this position being quite
roughly equal who would you rather be in
this position take a second and answer
that
well actually white is probably the one
pushing for more why because of the king
safety here the king safety of course we
have an open h file that we could
potentially use
and now one of the the front doors here
in front of the king are now actually
taken away as white's king is just much
safer right now
but we have no clear way just yet of how
to attack this king
so let's see what happens after b6 here
uh it just wanted to
be bishop b7 and also the fact that this
pawn
is attacked by this rook so if you want
to develop your bishop
finally anywhere over here well you're
going to have to worry about the b pawn
here so we played b6 we also
may be preparing c5 okay so b6 and queen
to g3 out of the way here
very nice lining up with the king
something like bishop g5 could be
devastating and deadly so we need to
start coordinating our pieces to
actually uh have a great king side
attack so queen to g3 threatening stuff
like bishop to g5
maybe even before rook h4 look at that
rook lift
this is scary already for the black
pieces after queen g3 there's queen to
d7
strong move here you're like queen d7
why would i jump right in front of my
bishop well
a key thing to remember and the key
thing to do is when you're being
attacked it's always good to trade the
pieces that are attacking you
so queen to d7 with the intention of
queen to g4 which is a very nice move
so after queen d7 we have h3 from a
dragon here
stopping queen g4 from ever happening
and then queen f5 and we live we
actually have to sit here
and do something we got to get the queen
closer over here because there are no
pieces around the king
meaning that we're going to be in a lot
of trouble with the black pieces if we
cannot defend
so the queen comes over here for the
defense maybe dropping into h7
or even g6 a ugly square to go to but we
do have opposite color bishops
so if we do have a trade with queen to
g6 we we could maybe draw the game but
this it's just a it's a lot of play left
but an ugly move to make his queen to g6
bishop g5 from dragon here threatening
bishop to f6 in some cases because again
we do have queen to g6
but again we have to develop our pieces
no matter what you got to get your
pieces off the back ring
and even if we moved it to e3 of course
this probably wouldn't be the best move
the fact of the matter is we do have to
develop our pieces in every single game
so bishop to g5 he gets out of the way
and here we are with c5
not only gaining some space but also
stopping this rook from rook lifting to
a very strong square which is rook b4
for the score and then we come over here
with rick h4 or rook f4 with very nice
uh threats against black's king
so after c5 there's rook to b3 from
dragging here threatening hey you know
what if i can't rook lift to b4
anymore i'm gonna go to rook to b3
pretty nice rook f3 is a strong move
follow with the same type of sequence i
mean what a rook lift here again black
is the one defending white is the only
one really playing for a big win here
and also looking for mistakes is what
black's doing um so after rook to b3
does queen to g6 just staying here hey
you know what
we want to block all of this now i would
love to get on queen g6 because if you
move your bishop
then we're going to take that queen and
not even think twice about it now after
queen to g6 there's rook to f3 once
again we're maybe going for something
like this
maybe in some cases even being able to
drop the bishop on f6 after removing the
queen
and replacing it with with the rook okay
rook f3
bishop e6 again you have to develop it
may suck to defend
but you have to develop your pieces
bishop e6 so now the rooks are connected
but
looks like black's definitely behind
here after queen f4 here with maybe
threats like rook to g3 or even bishop
f6
immediately super strong stuff here and
then queen to e4
says hey let's just get the ladies off
the board here we need to trade please
trade
and of course dragons like what are you
being trade what is that queen to d2
we're not trading anything
rook after c8 of course so we're making
some loot for the king in a way
king f8 actually so we can run away if
we need to just in case things get very
dicey
now one of the things to remember when
you are attacking is always make threats
i teach students this all the time is
about three threats or more in a row the
more threats you can make
the easier it is for your opponent to
make a mistake so here it is rookie one
bam hit that queen
we also get the file at the same time
very nice move queen moves out of the
way
queen h7 and then here's another one
rook g3 threatening stuff like bishop f6
or bishop h6
and look at this queen over here on h7
sad queen right
very sad queen but you know what we did
move this f rook so we can move our king
out of the way and have a nice day we
are running for the hills
getting away from civilization here king
f8 i'm out of the way and here we go
if you're playing white in this position
there's many moves that you can make
but there's a very strong move very fun
move to make
what would you play in this position if
you were dragging
here it is guys very strong move i hope
you're ready for it bishop f6
it's on the board oh my goodness this
man is ready to work or this machine
is going crazy here bishop f6 is just
going straight for it
just going for it let's do it whatever
and of course if g6 is just annoying
this bishop is sitting
on f6 just all in black's house not
fun so he says you know what hey we're
just going to take it we got to get rid
of this bishop you can't stay alone
you can't stay here for long so after
capturing on f6 we capture back and then
there's queen h4
which is a very strong move just kind of
you know taking taking a
stock and taking good advantage of the
dark squares because queen h6 is going
to be devastating queen f4 could be
scary due to queen d6
there's a lot of things that can happen
after queen h4 right also threatening f6
so
we think we're doing fine here black's
like i can defend
you know your pieces are further back on
the third third rank like that's the
best piece you have
is on the third rank i should be okay or
am i
what would you do in this position why
to move
here it is guys here it is dragon played
grook takes e6's on the board oh my
goodness look at that again rook takes
e6 sacrificing
rook takes e6 doesn't care about
anything rook takes e6 pretty nice so
very strong move here rick takes e6
sacrificing just the whole rook and says
take it if you like
so he says well i don't have anything
else better to do i need to take this
rook
and after rook takes we have rook to g4
so rick to g4 is now
being able uh giving us the square of f4
so we can drop or drop into d6
queen h5 and then he plays rook to g5
here which you also had queen f4 as an
option
rook to g5 is what was chosen from
dragon queen h8 going back here to
attack the f6 square
and then queen f4 there it is we're
trying to get that queen into d6 here
and here it goes rook to c6 pretty cool
move you know we have to defend and we
have to get this rook over here as well
but watch the watch how the maneuver of
the pieces really favor right here
especially with this very weak king even
being down a full
rook right now rook to c6 and rook to g6
here so we can put our queen on g5 maybe
g4
and also rook to h6 is a move as well
okay
black plays e5 and then white responds
with queen to g5 here very strong move
rick h6 rig g7 and maybe even f7 things
like this as well queen g5 and rook 2 e8
so we have now finally we have enough
pieces around the king
or is it is there enough here we don't
really know yet we're going to see what
happens rookie a
rook 2h6 threatening the queen and then
queen to ga
and after queen g8 a very strong move
here can you find me guys
can you find a move here i'm down a full
rook trading queens is
not a move that is not a move you cannot
trade queens okay
queen takes g8 will lose so you need to
keep the queens on so where are you
moving here queen
it is here it is queen h5 and we live so
rook h8
to be very great here and actually pin
the queen down to the king
and then we're going to win some
material at that case um even f7 and
some in some cases it's a very strong
stuff queen h5
rook e to e6 here and here we go you
know the queen is going to be lost now
this is something to pay attention to
here guys as this is the live position
from the game
now these two rooks two rooks are
usually
more times than not better than the
queen and if you are a beginner and
you're watching this video and you
didn't know that here
just because you're losing your queen
doesn't mean the game's over as long as
you have this compensation
which could be these two rooks here
usually just being better than the queen
because two is better than one and
also if you add it up think about the
point value here it would be ten points
for the rook
and the not the queen being nine so what
the job would be was you need to keep
these rooks con
excuse me connected you need to keep
them connected and you want to keep them
either doubled or like connected like
this now the queen here is the thing
that is going to be
very annoying because the shelter for
the king is non-existing so what we're
going to do is be doing
lots of checks try to gobble these pawns
and you need a plant you need just more
than a queen
you cannot do this with just the queen
you can't it's not going to happen
so what you have to do actually is have
other pieces maybe use the pawns and try
to clean these
because these are past pawns and also in
the same case of also
gobbling up as many pawns as we possibly
can but these rooks are passive
so white actually here even those
positions a little equal
actually uh white actually has a lot to
press for here as black is very passive
maybe if we could double the rooks this
way but then even in that case we could
play maybe f3 and just kind of chill now
after king takes g8 there's queen
e8 check and then king g7 and then we're
gonna fast forward just a little bit
because there's a lot of moves left so
g4 as we said our plan
was to make sure we use our queen and
the extra material we do have
to definitely try to win this game here
is the rooks are still passive now
they're not passive enough i mean they
are on the sixth rank and double
so getting past this without protection
of the other pawn here is going to be
very difficult for white
so after g4 there is rook f to e6 of
course threaten the queen
self-explanatory
and then there's a check king f6 check
again rookie 7 and h4 as we're just
marching walking the dogs in the park
all the way through
just having a nice day as we stroll
these pawns down the board trying to get
another queen
h4 and then there's d4 and h5 and we
live it's just gonna keep rolling the
pawns remember the plan
stick to the plan execute the plan h5
king e6
h6 and then rook c to c7 so now the
rooks are doubled more passively on the
seventh rank here and then queen to g8
check
and this is pretty simple here guys now
we actually played king to g2 from
dragon but
i didn't want to show this quick line
here because this was another way to do
it too uh which was playing g5 which is
pretty awesome
just pushing forward and then after king
f4 you have g6 again
rook e6 and then you just take it and
look at the beautiful
pawns just rolling down here i'm going
to queen this way or i'm going to queen
this way it doesn't really matter rook
g7
h a queen rook takes g6 and i mean this
this is over
as well so you know that very fun way to
do this there's many ways to play but
actually dragon shows
the king to g2 one actually just trying
to get every piece into play here
because of course you again you can't
just do it with your queen but the queen
in the pawns with
the help of the king here is going to be
awesome so rick f7 king 2f3
king e7 check and king e4 we're gonna
fast forward some moves here h7
rook c to ca and queen g7 check king to
d6 and here we go
queen h6 check king c7 g5 and we live
just keep pushing them
keep pushing them stick to the plan
right pretty easy plan rook f4 king
takes e5
threatening the rook here work f to f8
then we play queen d6 check
king has to go to b7 and g6 and look at
the pawns just strolling through the
park
d3 last ditch try here
of course try whatever you can you know
this is not bullet chest thickness
this won't work and this won't work here
but he's enjoying it anyway c takes d4
c takes d3 rook h8 queen to d7 check
queen to d5 or rook c7 then queen d5
rook to c6
and queen g8 the strong move it's
absolutely strong here this is going to
be over very soon
rook to uh c8 and here it is just take
the rook
just take it we're going to get a queen
anyway and then after g7 rookie eight
when we as we fast forward this game is
completely over here
so we're gonna take and then the rest is
history guys let's see how it finished
queen check pretty simple we make a
queen and we just go from eight and here
it is
queen c3 check king a4 queen b3 check
and can you find the mate guys there's
two of them on the board
okay can you find them which mate would
you choose but here's the here's the
mate here queen b5 of course is made
guys and queen a3
is the mate from the game what a game
here nice
double sacking away of course bishop f6
and
rook takes e6 that was very strong stuff
i hope you guys enjoyed today's game of
the day
i'm national master james canty the
third here with chess.com and i'll see
you guys
on the next video